avant ça y est babet connaît la position
parfaite pour driver avec trois mois
d'essai à son actif elle a décidé de
persévérer et profite d'un bilan
personnalisé proposé lors de cette golf
expérience la posture l'appui sur les
talons donc ça c'est important
et le relâchement des bras tout
l'après-midi le blue green de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
proposer des animations gratuites pour
s'initier ou se perfectionner à l'art du
golfe à l'aide de plusieurs ateliers là
trois ateliers qui permettent aux
débutants de prendre un club pour la
première fois en main donc à travers le
petit glas proches ou derrière moi le
practice une fois qu'ils ont validé ces
ateliers ils peuvent démarrer tout de
suite sur un sur un parcours de trois
trous coup là ils sont accompagnés par
un golfeur
après la ryder cup place à l'open de
france l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines souhaite faire une belle
place ou golf et le démocratiser
l'objectif pour 50 ans est très clair
c'est de faire découvrir le golf pour
tous montrés en fait démystifier un peu
l'idée reçue que le golf est pour une
élite qu'il faut vraiment être j'allais
dire professionnels pour faire du golf
que ça coûte très cher une activité qui
s'adresse aussi aux familles
exceptionnellement les plus petits
pouvaient faire leurs premiers pas sur
les terrains et apprendre les rudiments
de la petite balle blanche va respecter
la règle et le terrain le matériel est
juste jouer mettre la balle dans un trou
quant à babeth l'après-midi a suffi pour
trouver son swing